the future of european space policy was
up for debate as ministers responsible
for competitiveness in the eu met in
brussels
italian astronaut luca pamitano who
spent four months in the international
space station shared his experiences
with the council as ministers discussed
the challenges of space policy europe is
future
it's to me
it's one and the same word the future is
the evolution of society the the
evolution of our country is evolving
into something else something bigger
something better
but space also talks about future
it is the
the place where future things happen and
are prepared travel closer to earth was
also on the agenda ministers agreed on a
broad outline of reform for the travel
package directive the arrival of online
travel services has changed the way the
sector operates and the eu wants to make
sure that protection for travellers is
kept up to date the agreement means that
negotiations can begin shortly with the
european parliament with the aim of
concluding the reform as soon as
possible in other developments the
council reached an informal agreement on
safety standards the union's looking to
modernize safety requirements for
personal protection equipment and
devices using cables for transport like
cable cars and chair lifts the aims to
strengthen controls without placing a
heavy burden or heavy costs on industry